what makes a country happy
in 2021 the un published a report that
gives a score to each country on earth
according to the following six factors
in order to analyze and draw conclusions
from this data we need to be able to
understand or at the very least
visualize it obviously we cannot
visualize six dimensions all at once but
we can pick two or three factors for
example gdp social support and life
expectancy and visualize that here is
norway for example the us china russia
and the rest of the countries but if we
do it this way however then we lose some
possibly valuable information that might
be contained in other factors of the
data like freedom or generosity pca is
all about taking all factors combining
them in a smart way and producing new
factors that are one
and correlated with each other and two
are ranked from most important to least
important these new factors produced by
pca are called principal components and
they are constructed in such a way that
if you restrict your attention to the
first few components only you would
still get a fateful representation of
the data let us now explain how pca
picks its components for that let's take
the same data as before but limit
ourselves to the first three columns
only for simplicity and drop a few
countries so that the plot is not too
cluttered to pick the first component
pca asks the following question how can
we arrange these points on a line in a
way that preserves as much information
as possible
a first attempt is to project all of
these points on one of the 3d axes
but that corresponds to throwing away
all the other columns of the data so
maybe there is a better less wasteful
way
to answer that question let's take a
small detour to explain how projection
works
when you project a point x on a unit
vector u you get a new point x prime
whose magnitude is given by the inner
product between x and u and we can think
of the square of this inner product as
the amount of information about x that
is preserved after projection on u in
particular this quantity is maximum when
x is parallel to u and is minimal when x
is orthogonal to you
back to pca the first component that pca
picks is a unit vector that tries to
preserve as much information as possible
so it maximizes the sum over all
countries of the square of the inner
product while solving this optimization
problem might look intimidating at first
glance it is actually surprisingly easy
to solve if you use the so-called
lagrange multipliers method if you are
not familiar with the terms optimization
or lagrange multipliers you can either
simply ignore the next 20 seconds and
just take the results we're going to
reach for granted or first go watch my
beginner video series on optimization
so
in order to solve this problem let's
simplify the objective function a bit
with some not terribly complicated
manipulations we can rewrite this
expression as u times the matrix c times
u where c is known as the covariance
matrix of the data we then form the
lagrange function
take the gradient with respect to u and
set it equal to zero
in conclusion we know that the direction
u that preserves information the most
after projection satisfies the equation
c times u equals lambda u for some
unknown scalar lambda
and if this equation looks familiar to
you there is a reason this is exactly
the equation of the eigenvectors and
eigenvalues of c
and interestingly the amount of
information preserved after projection
on an eigenvector
is given by the corresponding eigenvalue
so clearly the best direction to pick is
the eigenvector with the largest
eigenvalue so for our example this is
what the eigenvector with the biggest
eigenvalue looks like and one way to
interpret this component is that roughly
all three original factors have equal
contribution and for this reason let's
call this component power
when we project the data points on this
component we know that icelandic
countries that we normally associate
with happiness like norway for example
are all positioned high on this axis
while countries like niger are
positioned low
of course this representation is not
perfect since you have countries like
singapore that rank high simply because
they have an unusually high gdp
but this is to be expected though
because we have only looked at the first
component that pca gives
let us now discuss the other components
of pca how do we pick the second
component for example
ideally the second component is a unit
vector that does not contain information
that is already contained in the first
component
or in geometric terms we want the second
component to belong to the subspace
orthogonal to u1 but other than that it
should maximize the same quantity as
before
and following reasoning similar to what
we did before we find that the second
component is given by the second
eigenvector of the covariance matrix of
the data and looks like this
in english this component is the
difference between individual factors
and social factors so let's call this
component balance
if we project the countries on the plane
spanned by the first and second
component we find that the happiest
countries seems to be the most balanced
ones and countries that are either very
high on the balanced axis like benin or
very low like turkmenistan are generally
less happy
and it's very interesting to revisit the
case of singapore
so while it's doing great in terms of
the power axis
the individualistic nature of its
citizens seems to make it less happy of
a country overall
more generally the directions picked by
pca are exactly the eigenvectors of the
covariance matrix you see every
symmetric matrix like c has n
eigenvector and eigenvalue pairs that
are orthogonal to each other the
eigenvectors are exactly the components
that bca picks and the eigenvalues give
you a sense of the importance of the
corresponding eigenvectors for our case
we see that pca suggests to look mostly
at the power component
and only look at balance for a more
refined analysis or to compare countries
of comparable power in fact we can make
things even more precise
if we divide all the eigenvalues by
their sum we see that the component
power explains about eighty-five percent
of the data while balance explains about
ten percent of the data and the third
component explains the remaining five
percent
this was the basics of pca and how it
can help you analyze high dimensional
data if you want to dive deeper into the
topic you can look at the references in
the description and if you like the
video like and subscribe and see you
next time
[Music]